la ville de la verrière qui va bientôt
disposer de son conseil municipal des
jeunes les élections ont démarré ce
mercredi elles se tiendront jusqu'à
demain jeudi le but initier les 11 15
ans à une démarche citoyenne et aider à
la réalisation de projets explication
Valérie oribau carnet de correspondance
en main les jeunes de la verrière âgés
de 11 à 15 ans venaient ce mercredi en
mairie pour voter pour leur futurs
représentants au conseil municipal des
jeunes parmi les futurs élus fara 13 ans
déjà plein d'idées en tête faire un
skate par pour plutôt les gens qui font
du skate si possible faire des fêtes
pour les
jeunes mettre des des dodanes ou des des
comment
s'appelle oui voilà des ralentisurs dans
les dans les vill queil y en a qui
roulent un peu trop vite et Kenny plus
jeune mais tout aussi motivé en cours il
nous avait montré des vidéos sur le CMJ
et ça m'a fait plusu alors je me suis
inscrit c'est une responsabilité 27
jeunes sont candidats seul 21 d'entre
eux seront élus pour 2 ans les six
autres deviendront suppléentss ce CMJ
est une première à La Verrière les
jeunes sont une telle richesse une
telle tel foisonnement d'idée c'est que
on peut pas passer à côté de ça
donc on pensa que c'était important de
leur permettre de s'exprimer des
réunions préparatoires ont permis aux
jeunes d'exposer leurs idées avant de se
présenter pour ses élections après un
premier vote aujourd'hui un second
s'effectuera jeudi jusqu'à 17h au
collège Philippe de Champaigne avant le
dépouillement à 18h en mairie c'est
l'URE des vux pour les élus de 50 et
même de tout le département et même de
toute la France et chaque soir nous
revenons régulièrement sur les
différentes cérémonies j'ine
vousz vousz déjà suffisamment de travail
avecintqutin Enel bonsoir Catherine ce
soir on va parler on va voir ce qui
s'est dit est ce qu'il faut retenir des
V qui son roul à guillancour hier
c'était Manamo aujourd'hui c'est gu et
ben oui tout à fait alors comme chaque
année ça s'est déroulé au Pavillon
valdec Rousseau il y avait du monde et
puis il y avait une ambiance une belle
ambiance en tout cas avec trois
associations qui ont d'abord commencé
par faire par faire le show en danse en
chant et on a même assisté à une flash
mob donc ça c'était vraiment le côté
vous bien le début était sympa alors
pour le côté culturel alors c'était ça c
culturel c'était ça mais
après plus sérieusement il y avait
vraiment une une présence politique en
tout cas importante parce que au côté de
François de on a v un ministre alors ça
devient une habitude il était à manid le
ministre des ivelines on va dire ça
comme ça maintenant on va le présenter
comme ça benoî Hamont ministre de
l'économie sociale et solidaire il était
à manie hier soir il était également à
Guill encour présent également député de
la circonscription ça c'est logique
François de Maier le maire de versaill
et puis d'autres maires de Montini de
voisin de bretonux de manie le préfet
qui était là et puis l'inspecteur
principal d'éducation Jean-Michel Coard
il y avait du monde he sur scène et les
vœux bien évidemment c'est quelque chose
de très sérieux même si on s'est un
petit peu s'amusé dans les différentes
comm commune il y a des annonces qui
sont faites elles sont souvent
économiques oui alors là c'était
vraiment deux annonces qu' ont débuté le
discours de François de Ligier le maire
de de Guill encs deux annonces donc
économique d'abord le crédit
île-de-fance le siège qui va connaître
prochainement une extension de son site
alors c'était une rumeur mais maintenant
c'est officialisé ce sont donc 20000 m
Carr supplémentaires qui seront réalisés
entre 2013 et 2014 pour accueillir 12200
employés supplémentaires et puis autre
satisfaction pour Guy en cour l'arrivée
de la société pharmaceutique Baxter au
côté de Sodexo et malacov meric c'est
sur le site de La Redoute de Bouvier et
il faut se rappeler que cette société
est implantée à MPa site de La Redoute
de Bouvier qui se développe justement
ces dernières années sur le secteur de
de Guille en cours des annonces plus
locales vie local à présent oui vraiment
vie locale en 2013 alors les sportifs on
a parlé sport avec le S Guillon cour les
sportifs peuvent se réjouir puisqu'ils
pourront inaugurer des nouvelles
tribunes au stade de Maurice Baquet et
puis plus largement pour toute la
population il y a la rénovation
l'espaive montant donc qui est aussi au
programme le démarrage du chantier du
nouveau groupe scolaire jeanlursa Elsa
Triolet et puis et le maire a beaucoup
insisté dessus été particulièrement
content la PAE de première Pier de la 4e
résidence universitaire VO par qu'il
manque des logements pour les étudiants
forcément c'est une bonne nouvelle et a
aussi été question d'éducation
guillancour accueillera en décembre 2013
dans un an le Congrès de l'Association
nationale des directeurs de l'éducation
des villes oui tout à fait et c'est pas
un hasard he parce que à gu en cours
cette année s'est installé le siège sais
pas si on peut dire ça comme ça le sièin
en tout cas l'inspect académique et à
guillancour on sait on aime bien on aime
bien l'école et du coup ce sera
évidemment l'occasion ce congrès fin
décembre de parler des rythmes scolaire
la ville a en tout cas fait le choix de
prendre son temps c'est ce qu' annoncé
François degier et donc le changement de
rythme scolaire ça ne se fera pas avant
septembre 2014 parce que dans certaines
communes on avait le choix certaines
régions c'était soit la rentrée 2013
soit en 2014 et à Guill encour 2014 pour
les familles qui nous suivent voilà
septembre 2014 pour le changement des
rythmes scolaires et le le maire en tout
cas annoncé qu'il souhaitait un dialogue
avec les différents partenaires que ce
soit les les enseignants ou bien les
parents d'élèves et on aura évidemment
l'occasion d'en reparler voilàil faudra
s'organiser pour les famillesment ça
sera pas forcément très simple du coup
ça fera plein de sujets sur TVF voilà à
suivre au cours des prochains Mo et des
plateau animés il manquera pas làdessus
les prochains vœux la commune de Trapp
ce sera vendredi soir avec guim alandin
et on l'imagine la présence du ministre
beno am alors voyons le suspense on va
le garder onire on pourrait faire un jeu
concours sur TVF ser présent mais c'est
sûr qu'il sera présent à trappe évidment
merci Catherine donc à lundi on passe à
la chronique culture du mercredi à
présent Joann souri qui va me rejoindre
bientôt